okay what do you think is it look like
I'm going to a funeral
should I add like a pop of color or
something more casual Nick I need your
help okay is this stunning or stupid I
still have time to take it back I'm
spike right so I go along with the whole
thing okay even if that's the case could
you just indulge me please
is this costume or Couture isn't bad
luck for me to see you in the dress Nick
that's a wedding the whole thing sort of
feels like a wedding what babe you got
you having a ring ceremony you know a
cake you're trying on a dress I mean
next thing I know you're gonna be you
asked me to take you on some
post-divorce honeymoon you know well you
know what draw this it would be nice to
have a little getaway
and then I wake up the next morning and
say we have to remodel Steven Sabrina
just liked our photo Susan and I made a
commitment to make our commitment work
you know what that takes masochistic
guilt no it takes commitment I don't
know how to describe it but every part
of me is miserable what am I supposed to
do now he's just gonna take some time
how long have you been coming here 15
years
you two what are you up to now I thought
from that moment on of my breakup as my
wake up I was actually trying to think
about this divorce being in a whole new
way why not have a party a divorce point
I need to understand how I a guy that I
think is pretty normal only has one
guest attendees party Nate please look
at your invite chips and dip at the
Savannah and Express isn't it pretty
it's pathetic if you want to have a
successful divorce party you've gotta
treat this as it was one as if it was as
important as your wedding help me get
over my ex-wife that sounds like a party
no invites celebrate my divorce
[Applause]
[Music]
like to register for the beer mug set
ping pong table and the 65 inch 4k ultra
HDTV with crystal clear pure pixelation
is this for a wedding
no it's for divorce
[Music]
you